your office undergraduate research
opportunities program and is basically
just a fancy word for undergraduate
research so the idea is that
undergraduates can work with grad
students and professors on their
research I was having lots of issues
yeah it's like being really inconsistent
about recognize I started out at MIT has
a math major but I started dabbling a
little with programming and I found that
I was really interested in it and I was
looking through some of the projects at
the Media Lab and I found this really
awesome project that has that sort of
interaction with technology that is the
vision in the future the basic idea is
to use computers to sort of augment
physical spaces instead of just altering
how you perceive reality it actually
changes reality by projecting on top of
it you have the computer the projector
and the camera is built into one you
take the idea of like the form factor of
a light bulb and then instead of having
a filament you replace that with cameras
and projectors and that sort of stuff so
it doesn't just sort of shine light down
they can see everything and then react
to that and project different things
down instead of just plain light
luminarc brings together electrical
engineering mechanical engineering
computer science we've had your ups in
each of these different disciplines so
if I don't want to go to the database in
a great endeavor yeah I like the most
recent week that we have on the database
okay that's a great solution let's just
do that the deal is very simple you know
it's a team and everybody gets
responsibility and get thrown to the
deep cold water very quickly and they
need to swim doesn't mean we let people
drown but it means they need to chart
their course and teach themselves and
the process we learn a lot we could also
pull some from the performance records
one of my roles in the project is to
explore what the system can do the
natura app was really to demonstrate how
quickly could develop on the system I
was told naturals coming the day before
and I just started pulling information
from the website and build it within a
day you sort of Mark a region that
you're interested in which is you know
what you think of is a button and then
it sort of watches your hand and anytime
a hand goes over that button it sort of
fires off an event and then we can
respond to those events you could
project the color of the makeup right
onto your skin itself and compare the
skin tone it's not so far off another
future that is sort of incomprehensible
that we'd have this in our homes in 5-10
years but it's still sort of futuristic
enough to that it's sort of a really
really cool research topic a lot of web
technologies are developing so quickly
that some of our Europe's have come in
this is sort of what they grew up as
their first languages and so they have a
fluency with them that we don't have yet
one of the big benefits of Europe is
that it gives you a lot of hands-on
experience so vs. classes we have these
very structured projects that's like oh
you do this and then you like get a
great on end to do like right or wrong
what's cool about research is you don't
have like a writer or wrong you come up
with an idea you have a goal and then
you sort of work towards and have a
product at the end so you have something
that you can actually show for it
instead of some little class project the
research is really cutting edge and to
be involved could really help you gain
the skills and knowledge that you don't
get from the classroom experience the
project is too big for any one or two
person to do on their own it would not
have been possible without our ops